Speaker 1: The Trump writer known in the media
as the Q and on Shaman has been sentenced
to 41 months in prison, and we're going to
talk about the sentence.
We're going to talk about consequences in
general, the way that these court cases are
going and really what the philosophy or approach
should be in terms of sentencing for these
individuals now to step back for a second
and kind of set the stage.
There are hundreds of alleged Trump rioters
whose cases are pending right now, and we're
starting to see sentences, sentences that
are very mild, ranging all the way up to several
years.
Now, when we talk about consequences for the
Trump riots.
One side of that are the consequences for
individuals that participated people like
the QAnon Shaman, Jacob Chansley and others.
And we're going to talk about that in a moment.
There's a whole other side to consequences,
which has consequences for those that instigated
it.
Those that created the environment in which
half of the Republican Party or more believed
that the election was actually won by Donald
Trump and that Joe Biden stole it in some
way.
And thus it was in some way justified to go
to Washington DC on January 6th and do what
they did.
There have been no consequences for those
people whatsoever, and that includes the former
President Donald Trump himself.
It includes people around Donald Trump.
It includes members of the House of Representatives.
It includes members of the Senate.
It's a very, very long list.
And when we talk about consequences for them,
really, we're probably talking about political
consequences.
I don't think there's any chance, nor arguably
even a legal basis for charges against someone
like me.
And I don't know to pick someone.
Madison Cawthorn, I don't know, you know,
the people that were going around fomenting
and instigating.
There's a question as to whether there will
be political consequences for some of those
people.
The answer is also probably not, because most
of them are in very red districts, safe districts.
The people in the Senate, many aren't even
up for reelection in 2022.
So that's one side that's not going particularly
well.
Now to the sentences and to the news of today,
we're starting to see sentences stack up for
some of these riders on the I think it was
the Monday bonus show.
We talked about roughly the same amount of
time, about 40 months for one of the other
rioters.
One of the most prominent riders is this guy,
Jacob Chansley, known as the Q Shaman.
He has now been sentenced to 41 months.
The man known as QAnon Shaman, who stormed
the Senate chamber on January six, adorned
in face paint and wearing a fur helmet with
horns, was sentenced to 41 months behind bars
on Wednesday.
34 year old Jacob Chansley from Phenix, Arizona,
pleaded guilty in September to one felony
count of obstruction for his role in trying
to block the counting of the 2020 Electoral
College votes.
He faced up to 20 years in prison on the charge.
Federal prosecutors themselves had only asked
for 51 months.
That was the longest requested sentence so
far in the Trump riots.
U.S. District Judge Royce Lamberth handed
down a 41 month sentence and also three years
probation, once released.
In sentencing, Chansley, Lamberth said he
thought Chansley was quote, Genuine in your
remorse, but the severity of the crime warrants
the sentence.
What you did here was horrific.
As you can now see QAnon Shaman, of course,
as we're showing you here is this guy who's
shirtless picture wearing the worn fur hat
and the flag and the megaphone and the whole
thing.
Images of this guy went viral very, very quickly.
Videos showed him inside and outside the Capitol
building, yelling at police officers, leading
a mob, eventually getting into the Senate
chamber where he scrawled.
It's only a matter of time.
Justice is coming on paper, covering the desk
where Mike Pence had been presiding minutes
earlier.
He was in court yesterday with a beard, a
green prison jumpsuit addressed.
The court referenced Jesus Gandhi and the
movie Shawshank Redemption, expressed remorse
and said he would do everything differently.
I was wrong for entering the Capitol.
I have no excuse.
The behavior is indefensible.
Now, Chansley asked for a time served, meaning
he gets credit for the time he's already spent
behind bars, saying he's not dangerous, he's
not violent, he's not an insurrectionist or
a domestic terrorist, and he's nothing like
the other people he has been incarcerated
with.
So what?
What's the takeaway here, right?
First of all, there are people who are annoyed
at only 41 months.
A few things to note.
First of all, the prosecutors only asked for
51 months.
So oftentimes we see could be 20 years when
prosecutors say given the circumstances, we're
only asking for 51 months.
It's rare, not unheard of, but rare.
Judges sentenced people to more than prosecution
asks for number two.
He did take a guilty plea and he did show
remorse.
Now we could say the remorse isn't genuine.
The judge felt that it was, but it is one
of these situations where if he were.
The earlier sentences are increasingly people
who are taking pleas.
It would be reasonable to think that those
who are going to push not guilty maybe go
to trial, et cetera, if they are found guilty.
We could see even longer sentences.
Trials take longer than please.
All else being equal.
So we won't know about those sentences for
a period of time.
Also, I got a couple of emails from people
saying, why wasn't this guy charged with treason?
That is very, very difficult.
And typically prosecutors are not going to
do that unless they are very confident in
the evidence and state of mind is a factor
there.
Same.
Same with something like sedition.
So that's just really tough.
It's not surprising that the Q and on Shaman
was not charged with treason.
Now the Fox News perspective on this, at least
the perspective of Fox News contributor Will
Cain, is that the QAnon Shaman was brainwashed,
I guess, by the left while he was in custody.
Speaker 2: Insidious part Tucker he was submitted
to, and he did submit some type of brainwashing.
I mean, they have made all of these.
Jan. six defendants essentially repent from
any beliefs they ever had an echo critical
race theory ideas, read the right books and
tell a judge they apologize for everyone and
everything they've ever been.
It's really gross and it's a violation of
due process, and it's just a violation of
our sense of justice.
Speaker 1: Now, I don't know if the references
to Gandhi or whatever were part of that.
I'm not really sure, but that's what we might
call an alternative perspective.
And that's actually something that's being
repeated a lot by the right, which is these
alleged insurrectionists are not only being
treated unfairly.
Some of them by being kept detained in pretrial
detention.
They're not allowed out on bail or they can't
afford it.
They're also being brainwashed as the cases
against them are going forward.
OK.
So overall, the prison sentences are getting
longer and longer.
In the last week, we saw the two longest prison
sentences of above 40 months.
The lesser charges for the Trump riders are
kind of being moved out of the way first,
and I expect that some of these are going
to get longer and longer over time.
One thing that is curious is why aren't Trump
supporters angry that the rioters are sort
of being left out to dry?
They did the thing that they believed Trump
wanted them to do.
They showed up.
They tried to interfere with the count.
They tried to prevent Joe Biden from becoming
president.
They did the thing that Trump thought was
right.
Remember Trump in the video on January six,
said it's time to go home.
But I get why you're here.
Makes sense that you're here.
You're doing a beautiful thing.
We love you, I believe, he said.
But now they're just kind of being left out
to dry.
Why aren't they all furious with Trump about
that?
I don't know.
Just a question